okay all right more questions uh jesse
salazar says conan when will you start
coming up with names for your facial
expressions
i have names for my uh facial
expressions i just choose not to
disclose them but this is called the
you william that
um uh anthony
mario and zetty are you excited to go
back to new york at the end of october
yes i am it'll be good to go back to new
york city and uh have all those things i
love pizza uh bagels
um
drinkable water all that kind of stuff
that i enjoy uh alex hamm says conan did
you ever do improv comedy
yes
cjb bando will you throw seth a stag
party if so how you do it oh man a conan
stag party is the best stag party of all
if you know what i mean
we all sit around and we drink diet coke
then we have bagel chips
then we watch andy griffith shows on
nick at night and then it's right to bed
at 9 30. uh and finally king curtis are
you a fan of birthdays if so you should
wish me a happy 20 late 20th birthday
that's so lame are you a fan of
birthdays yeah i'm a fan of my birthday
i'm not a fan of your birthday i don't
care about your birthday but anyway
happy birthday because i'm a big fan of
birthdays i love it when you have a
birthday king curtis
right there and we'll hit little